you would go to his house that bubbles
chip when he got a certain age yeah you
couldn't with bubbles no bubbles in a
cage
yeah a few times and a champion I'm
going crazy is that the bubble she said
yes Don't Go Near The Cage really I
thought bubbles was don't go over to you
all right I'm going in for another one
are you ready
wait a second Arnold Schwarzenegger
[Music]
Arnold Schwarzenegger you know and my
daughter Willow you know she's nine you
know she's also a movie star and a pop
star we can do anything you know she's
basically a tiny Will Smith with
estrogen and Barbie dolls yeah my seeds
are like taking over the world
I'm a Jedi feed my sperm uh yeah check
it out okay
Joe Rogan is here yeah that's crazy man
dude do you guys feel liberated after we
go behind the paywall yeah I feel
different here I feel a lot more free
now I can say that compilation they have
of me but live yeah I'm gonna say it
right now
I am sick of
negativity
I want people to be positive context to
say that's crazy
you're a bad [ __ ] around
yeah
um I don't like Ryan Reynolds at all
exactly absolutely and [ __ ] yeah the
voices kind of did get me where I am
tonight all right you're doing good
buddy you're doing good you're very
likable shofar
keep it up do not look at the lady in
the front row with the big Nikes all
right
focus on the monologue you'll be fine oh
you're doing the voices your dragon tail
got his knife
[Applause]
rolling down the street smoking in dough
sipping on gin and juice
[Applause]
I like big butts and I cannot lie
I can do this and it can sound exactly
like Jeff Goldblum are you ready for
this uncanny my life it finds a way he
got everything he got everything in yeah
it's like listening into a mirror Alan
all that I did uh auditioning Colin Jose
wrote a Sketcher I was Alan Alda
auditioning for Biff and Back to the
Future
and I was like uh they uh hey why don't
you make like a tree and get out of here
[Laughter]
I tell you this is a great this is just
great I love this it's a great movie
uh sorry Mr salderberg is about time to
take my shirt off
it's all right all right all right that
was really good Matt Damon who you know
does the best in Matthew yeah I'm doing
him Matt Damon that was good though they
doing a new uh bad boys they doing bad
boys three but that but they're not
bringing Will Smith and Martin Lawrence
back man
how crazy they got Jay-Z and 50 Cent
they gonna be in there driving to save
someone LJ you want to take the wheels
and I'm tired right now and lay down in
the back seat or something yo it's crazy
out there son I heard they got guns and
anything it's bananas yo for real they
got guns yes sir yep
Chris Rock is directing what are y'all
doing
Jay-Z
how you get Beyonce with them big lips
hey Denzel Washington is the acting
coach so uh so you telling me you want
to be actors now
[Applause]
oh
so we go to the movies but it's hard
because Michael got to sneak in the
movie right before it start so Michael
coming in like with a ninja suit on he's
hiding and all black all of a sudden I'm
sitting there where's Michael and then I
turn around he's like hey Chris I'm like
oh man how long you been here for about
five minutes
I'm sorry
hey man look this is the [ __ ] right
here man for real if anybody want to say
something man for real he gonna be in
rush hour four yeah so um
man
give me your hat I like a pill no I'm
[ __ ] with you put it back on
uh this
I used to do this thing on Tinychat on
Twitter where I would go into the chat
room and not have a picture and I would
just be different celebrities and the
the people's favorite one was Katt
Williams and one day Katt Williams
actually came into the room and I knew
it was him because he had pictures of
his babies that were not online I knew
it was him and he got mad at me too he
was like do you know my babies you
ignorant son of a [ __ ]
so here's the thing sir first what you
need to do is get somebody that you
actually sound like because you don't
sound nothing like me BoBo that's what
he said and the people in the room I had
you know got friends Affairs they were
like no that ain't cat William J sound
more like Katt Williams than you do and
I was like yo bro that's the actual dude
because I can hear it but they were like
no we got your back Jay get that fake
cat out of here I was like y'all just
this the real Katt Williams Oh look who
are diaphragm for an elephant oh don't
be afraid oh look Mr Happy oh oh I can't
fight with that oh look oh oh big penis
oh oh well actually I was doing
I was doing Robin like senile like age
70.
I'm doing punch lines that make no sense
whatsoever or look oh oh look
oh her oh don't be afraid oh oh Mr happy
or her or her you know because you know
I I have um you know I invested so much
you know money into small businesses and
you know I think people you know they
really need to just you know take me
person you know take me for real because
you know I'm not playing hold on you
housewipe
you ain't got the answers man you ain't
got the how what is your clothing line
we don't even know
clothing line
[Laughter]
show me all your secrets
Come a Little Closer
don't make me go too far into Arnold
who's fully like smoking a cigar at a
giant oak desk in front of a six foot
oil painting of himself from Pumping
Iron days it was everything you wanted
to be he's like hello good to see you
that's the before this is the after
you're the best it's all you want the
best that's all you want
I don't want to be king all right well
let's see uh
you know mine I was wearing this guy oh
it's a bit of a surfer
also Heath Ledger no no no no no close
close oh the other side of the country
yeah Thor
yeah
that's great thanks buddy that was
really good was it good yeah you're
strong at this come on girl
[Laughter]
what would Superman say
s
it was Gilbert Godfrey yeah I'm outing
Japan
[Laughter]
I used to watch Disney all the time and
I would pick up the impression so I
would go around like do you really think
you know what you're saying everybody
was your fault everybody all right well
let's see y'all
in our mind I was wearing this guy did
uh
always a bit of a bit of a tall guy uh
Lisa from 30 yard footer grunt yeah
close close oh it's a bit of a surfer
also Keith Ledger no no no no close
close oh the other side of the country
yeah Thor Thor because you see him in a
club and he sees he sees some girls Hi
how are you doing you like BMWs when
girls go what do you like you like BMW
you like cars you like BMWs and crazy
he'd take the girls out and go get a BMW
I mean he was that crazy you know what
I'm saying come on come on let's look at
the view and open up the BMW dealership
no idea
no idea I was supposed to be a hyena I'm
supposed to happen
I was supposed to be here I thought that
was the actual person
you know what separates me okay from
like Hollywood directors okay is it did
I bet like I have a huge head all right
okay now I don't mean I have to be ego
okay because I don't all right I mean my
actual head is huge all right I mean I
have to sleep sitting up okay like the
Elephant Man or I'll die all right but
but okay get this though okay it was my
huge head okay to thought up who is
perfect to play marcellus's why